the Joe Rogan experience what kind of
truck cardi driving regular life please
don't say like a Prius no that was bumpy
like if you like oh I just travel the
other day I was throwing some things
into the recycling bin and I'm like I'm
just trying to do my part because let's
face it I burn fuel for a living yeah
right how much fossil fuel I wonder if
you have a chart how much fossil fuel
the average person burns oh I would not
be doing well on that that would not be
I would not do well with the tree
huggers or vegans of the world and all
the people loving animals like me I mom
all those people I love the forest I try
and eat vegetables most of the time
things like that but yeah I also don't
do my part when it comes to my job what
kind of car do you drive
so I've had cars for years through
through the manufacturer so um this past
year we were sponsored by Ford so I had
a I had a Ford Expedition EL I didn't
know what ailment
it means extra long oh that's for space
in the back yeah it was yeah hook you up
with a Mustang Shelby well that's not
very practical
we weren't even allowed to customize the
customize the wheels on that thing so it
was Barris bare bones because that was
part of the contract garbage you can't
get anything dressed up when they hook
you up with a raptor so I could have had
a raptor I guess you get it like trucks
aren't really me whatever yeah so and
then I had a Tahoe when I drove a Chevy
before that I would think that you would
want something fast um so that I I
bought my first car and that's the last
car I bought oh yeah a long time ago I
bought a Mercedes ml63 AMG it was like a
SUV souped-up SUV that was a long time
ago I was like 10 years ago I bought a
Range Rover so since then you've just
been using manufacturer across from the
sponsors because they're free dollars
yeah and they're not you know whatever
is freeze free is that like a part of
the contract like that's the only car
you're allowed to drive
probably not but but that's drive to the
racetrack probably one driving here yeah
company car yeah probably good move yeah
yeah but other drivers have other cars
too but do you think that once you
retire you will start like going calm
down I'm gonna need to get home I'm not
a car girl
what nope not a car uh I'm sorry
disappoint you mean how you how'd you
even say those words I know I do you
know who you are yes and I'm not a card
trick I know I'm a race car driver woman
I don't even know how many cylinders are
in things I'm just I just drive them I'm
just good at that you don't know how
many cylinders no no I think well we
have eight that's so crazy
I just lost so many fans yeah how could
he be such a good driver and not know
anything about cars I don't need to
that's good way of looking at it I don't
build it I don't try didn't have to go
to school for engineering remember the
beginning of her trap ten years old ten
years I remember so yeah I just I I can
drive them you need to get yourself on
those new Shelby gt500 700 horsepower
yeah I just announced it Oh Oh Shelby
new 100k not the GT not the gt500 or
those oh you mean the 42 but Shelby just
put out a new month well the problem of
those 4 GTS they're awesome but the
paddle shifts you want a manual yeah you
want to stick yeah Alex yeah it's more
fun yeah it's just some more racy it's
just more fun I have a Bronco a 1971
Bronco and you're not driving that is
you know it's a stick it's like it's not
that fast but it's just easier
testosterone mechanical it's mechanical
feel it's analog you know I just like my
car to be good off the line
I bought a Lamborghini a long while back
and it didn't have cupholder so I was
like oh this is stupid
he's not practical so yes and then I
bought the Mercedes and that had a cup
holder that had a couple cup holders yep
so it was good but then it you know
technology evolved and it didn't have
bluetooth to play my music so I was like
well I'm gonna have to get rid of this
and that was when I started driving for
Chevy and then I got a Tahoe and I like
that and then I got
for cheffing they didn't give you a
Corvette I didn't ask for one how could
you not want one you driving force in a
practical car if I wanted those Corvette
I could buy one okay I know you good but
I would say be like come on hook it up
I'm not yeah come on I'm not a car
girl we went over there understand this
though I keep keep want to catch you in
that lie no I don't care I just I have
cars are like purses for me I just need
one nice one and when it wears out I'll
get a new one you don't like purses not
really really cared girl just needed one
that looks good and just one that's it
yeah what about shoes no I like shoes oh
I have a lot of shoes there you go your
girl I'm definitely a girl but not
purses watch my own curl my own hair
today well that's crazy makeup yeah okay
my shoulder hurts a little bit but
hairspray what is this definitely I'm
very much a girl I believe you that's
what if people ask me what it what is it
about you that people would be surprised
and I'm telling them like much more
girly away from the track than you'd
think because I'm really aggressive at
the track and I don't look very happy
and away from the track I'm I try and be
funny and I smile more and I'm much more
relaxed
[Applause]